Now you may have noticed, one of the annoying things about
using input this way, is that it's distracting to have the
address bar on the screen when I'm taking a picture. One
thing you might want to do is take your app full screen.
This is pretty simple to do. Just grab the dom element
that you want to make full screen, that you want to
be the root of the window and call its requestFullscreen method.
Now, at the time of this recording, requestFullscreen is still vendor
prefixed, so we'll have to use webkitRequestFullscreen and
mozRequestFullScreen. One important thing to notice here is the
difference in capitalization. Kind of annoying, but it'll
get fixed sooner or later. One important thing to
note is that you can only call this API in the handler for a user action. Like,
clicking on a button. This is to avoid
apps forcing users into full-screen mode. You can't just
do this when you're loading the page.